speaking of love I love this guy - his
name is Tyrell Alvin McCraney he's a
playwright a professor and a co-writer
of the oscar-winning screenplay you know
at moonlight this movie won best picture
at the 2017 Academy Awards McCraney is
now turning to television for his new
project it's called David makes man it's
about a fourteen-year-old prodigy
handling the pressures of an elite
education and the dangers of his Miami
neighborhood at the same time this is a
preview I can't have you I walk through
over town over tected we do a man oh so
you want my protection I know you got
more to do this house walk with us we're
good worried there's my lord - don't
ain't nothing more important than family
so true Tarell Alvin McCraney is a
creator and co-executive producer and
joins us at the table it's on The Oprah
Winfrey own Network we should point that
out they had the first episode last
night and I remember the pitch you
didn't have Oprah at hello but by the
time the pitch was over she said it was
one of the best no not one of the best
pitch that she's ever heard so Bravo to
you to Elmo thank you Bravo Bravo this
is about David which which we've been
told is loosely based on your childhood
but you said yeah but yeah but I mean
it's a
the cornerstone of David is about the
experiences I had growing up in a place
called Homestead Florida made really
popular recently before the detention
center of 12 children down there but
also a hurricane call Andrew came in
decimated everything when I was 12 years
old but when I lived there I remember
going to a magnet school program out of
the projects that look very much like
that building in on the show and I
remember just thinking and feeling
learning how to be very different at
school than I was at home so living two
worlds for yourself double-consciousness
doublespeak code-switching at all terms
even just to get on the bus in the
morning and I remember and I've started
talking to folks about that I talked to
my friends my peers an actor named Andre
Harland who was who was also in moon
night and we talked about it and then I
started pitching the story out to folks
I went to mbj Michael B Jordan and he
started to tell me about the time AJ
that's what we call it okay who is one
of the executive producers on the show
yeah and Michael talked about his time
grump growing up in Newark and how he
had very similar experiences and then I
pitched the show a tone and someone made
Oprah sit in front of me they asked her
to sit in front of me and which you know
I'm very nervous and shy I know you
can't tell but I get really nervous
inside of here I have Oprah Winfrey
listening to me pitch this show what was
your pitch my pitch was that I think a
lot of folks go through this experience
I think it's a unique experience in that
a lot of young people in the America in
fact I was talking to one of your
producers the other day and they were
like I'm from pariah which is you know a
block of stone's throw from homestead
I live at homestead till I was ten we
talked off camera I realize his
homestead was absolutely and and so
folks our folks really understand this
notion of how I am at home I'm not in
school I'm being socialized to be
different in that way and how you and
what tools you pick up to survive that
kind of doubleness that those two lives
and then the extremes can really happen
when you are in the margins of poverty
when you're coming from a place of
poverty going into a place of access you
really have to learn how to code switch
in order to survive yeah and so what do
you hope people take away from this who
have not lived this experience and are
seeing it on screen for the first time
well I hope you expect I know one of the
things that's been really helpful is
that we've been screening it a lot and
what and what's drawing folks in is that
the tenderness of a young person and and
the things that you begin to pick up as
a young person we that happens all
across the board and we all remember
those moments of looking at our mentors
looking at our teachers looking at our
parents and taking on the the mechanisms
that you may use we're trying to use
those adult mechanisms in our own lives
just trying them out you know you might
repeat a phrase that you heard someone
say and you watch David use those things
use those moments to really try to carve
out a survival a way to survive
I like your title David makes man yeah
what does that mean
it's miss Oprah
really gravitated towards that title
because it's active right it sounds in
one part because of the way scans David
makes man biblical but at the same time
it really hones in to the point that
we're watching this young person make
himself as as we speak make him
into an adult before our eyes I'm
curious when you talk about
code-switching and that creates a
strength in terms of being a survivor
sure is the codes the skill to code
switches it is it is a good thing and a
bad thing oh yes I mean there's nothing
I mean everything that we we learn about
survival is is a good and bad thing
meaning that at some point do you always
need it to survive one of the things
that was really interesting is that I
brought this pitch to own at a time that
Miss Winfrey was also doing a segment on
60 minutes about acute childhood trauma
yeah and and that trauma when we're
young we go we say to ourselves oh I'm
in a survival mode you know I'm in
fight-or-flight and you start making
mechanisms in order to survive at all
times but then no one tells you when to
stop doing that
yeah it was life-changing for her
because she said people always say
what's wrong with you when you see if
there's somebody acting out when the
question really should be what's what
has happened to you but it made its
debut less at this tweet caught my eye
this morning from dr. Michelle law she
said at Oprah applause applause applause
I have to use a bathroom but refused to
take my eyes off the TV I'm totally in
spellbound by David makes man which
makes you happy because you said this is
a show you have to watch with your eyes
it deliberately has few commercials
because you want people to sit and watch
yeah it's built instant its cinematic
for a reason yes weight shot yeah
absolutely we want you to have to sit
and take in those segments you you know
you got to get your nachos you got to
get your popcorn and put it in front of
you and then watch with people and so
that you can talk about it together
you're connecting with viewers but you
also connect with students or a drama
professor at Yale other things from your
upbringing and your background your
education that you're using in the
classroom Oh every day I again I'm
extraordinarily nervous and shy by
Nature I am that's the survival
mechanism you learn you learn that you
present confidence yeah present smiles
you draw people and you ask them
questions you compliment them I learned
all those skills right and at some point
I forget to turn them off yeah cuz you
did say you know I like that shade of
green yeah one last question okay here's
your Oscar is that you oh yeah I don't
need the carrot right it's heavy
well we're so glad you're here and David
is here akela who plays David so we're
gonna do Facebook live right after the
show do you mean
hi David there's David hokule'a I Akili
sorry Hayek Ely he plays a title
character and David makes man we thank
you very much thank you David makes man
airs on Wednesday nights on own so the
first one aired last night you can still
watch it though join us right after the
broadcast on Facebook live with Tyrell
in the six you know action plays David
that's a Keely McDowell